-Guys, it is
the end of the week.
That's usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my in-box,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was running a bit
behind today, so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd just like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now.
Is that cool with you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
The best. Thank you, thank you.
James, can I get some
thank-you-note-writing
music, please?
[ Soft music playing ]
That's perfect.
That is the perfect music.
-Yeah.
-Gosh, he's --
-Wow.
Hold it. Hold it.
Hang in there, bud.
[ Drumroll ]
Hold it. Not yet.
Hold it.
That's it. You broke the record.
There you go.
That's it. You did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Pretty good. Not bad.
[ Laughs ]
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, Milk Crate Challenge,
for raising a lot of
questions, but mainly,
how do so many people
have access to 49 milk crates?
Where are they getting these?
-Great idea.
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you, "Candyman,"
for being the only time
I have to say
someone's name five times,
besides when I'm trying to
get Alexa's attention.
Alexa, stop.
That's the second time
I said the C-word.
I'm not doing it anymore.
-What's that?
-No, I'm not saying that name.
-Oh. Yeah, don't say it.
-Even if -- I know it's fake,
but just why?
Why put it out there?
-No, don't put it out there.
-I'm not going to
put it out there.
-Don't even play Sammy Davis Jr.
version of it.
-[ As Davis ]
♪ Who can take the sunrise ♪
♪ Sprinkle it with dew ♪
♪ Da-da-da-da,
to make a miracle or two ♪
♪ The [clears throat] can ♪
-♪ Oh, Jeff Bezos can ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you, Krispy Kreme,
upping their
"free doughnut if you're
vaccinated" campaign
to two free doughnuts
or, as that one guy
on Facebook put it,
"I'm holding out for
a full dozen."
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you,
giving plants as a gift,
for being a fun way of
telling your friend,
"Here, you kill this."
With a plant. I don't know.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you,
automatic minivan doors,
for making me feel like
I'm entering a spaceship,
instead of my 2012 Kia Sedona.
Wow!
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, St. Louis arch,
for looking like
the Washington Monument
doing downward-facing dog.
A little yoga ref.
-A little yoga ref.
What's up, Peloton?
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you, ascots, for just
being ties worn exclusively by
guys who challenge each other
to hot-air-balloon races.
Too specific.
-Very specific.
-That's a specific joke, yeah.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you,
coin-operated binoculars,
for charging me 50 cents to say,
"Oh, yeah, I see it."
Oh.
Yeah.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, bathrobes,
for being the official wardrobe
of both fancy hotel guests and
biggest neighborhood dirtbags.
"What are you up to?
I'm waiting for the dozen."
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you, sofa beds,
for managing to be bad at both.
Yeah, there you go.
There you have it.
Those are our "Thank You Notes."